this week on ford former cia operative
and texas congressman and author of the
new book american reboot will herd this
week on forward
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
forward podcast former cia officer and
u.s representative uh for texas 23 i
want to say was that the district that's
correct that's correct and author of the
great new book american reboot an
idealist guide to getting big things
done will hurd welcome to the podcast
will hey thanks for having me on man
it's a pleasure
no problem so uh your background is
fascinating you seem like a fictional
character
so
so what do i mean by that i mean now i
feel like i i know a great deal about
your life having read your book um i
confess that
i was
most drawn to
uh your stories of being a cia operative
because like a lot of people i dreamt
about being a spy or an american james
bond when i was a kid but you actually
went out and did it
best job on the planet best job on the
planet
now so you uh
graduated from college uh in texas and
then
immediately went to the cia is that
right that's correct you know my degree
was in computer science and i thought i
was going to
i thought i thought i was going to go
work for ibm and code you know i had an
internship there and you know worked
with one of their top programmers and i
had never really been outside of texas
um you know i had i had gone to langston
oklahoma
and i'd been to indiana as a kid
but i decided once one after my freshman
year in college to take up two
journalism classes in mexico city
and fell in love being in another
culture i thought it was cool
seeing things i only read about books
right and i was just blown away in the
city that international studies
as a minor
and the first class i took in
international studies this former cia
badass right um it's sorry tough guy
tough guy i don't know that's fine
that's okay um and and he told these
amazing stories about being an
old-school cold warrior and being in
moscow
and being in mexico going toe-to-toe
with russian intelligence officers and i
was just like i want to do that and that
began my interest and when i graduated i
went into the cia and started when i was
22.
so how the hell does someone join the
cia
i say this everybody thinks i'm joking
it's an application and interview
process right like you you really do um
you know uh texas a m where where i went
to undergrad was uh
because of jim olson this was the guy
that that told me these amazing stories
it's kind of a pipeline there there to
the agency but you do you do a number of
interviews the number of tests um
there's a there's a poly a psyche val
and all these kinds of things and
um and i got in and it was it was
awesome
and because they don't take many people
straight out of my undergrad and so i i
basically was in in headquarters in
langley for two years before i did
training and my my career literally
started the day of the uss cole bombing
in um you know the the u.s navy
destroyer that was attacked by al-qaeda
in the gulf of aden off of the coast of
yemen back in october of 2001 and that
was the day i drove my car from
from san antonio to washington d.c and
then my career ended in afghanistan um
dealing with al qaeda there
oh it's quite a set of bookends so why
do you think they decided to hire you
out of undergrad which is somewhat
unusual
well look
one it was um
they're looking for people that have
good grades i had really good grades and
not really good let's let's be hon i had
good grades i met there i met their
minimum of what was required and then i
had a number of leadership um
experiences when i was at was at
university and so i was our student by
president you know 43 000 students i
would say it's like a it's like being
the mayor of a small town and um i you
know and led the university through a
pretty horrific um
um
accident we had 12 kids killed
when our bonfire collapsed this was a
tradition and that had been going on for
almost 100 years
and about 24 other kids were injured
then i spoke i i had enough spanish
to get by and and operate
and um and so and i had experience
overseas right so i i had that
experience of of working of studying
abroad in mexico but i also worked in a
factory in the philippines that
manufactured integrated circuits
it's just like it sounds i was working
in this big old factory
um and and so you know demonstrated
ability to operate and be successful in
overseas environments all those things
together um you know yeah it's a pretty
com compelling application so
um so you started headquarters in
uh langley virginia so it was
that meant you moved to dc from texas
as a 22 year old and then eventually you
wound up in the famous farm which is the
the training program
um so you say that which is not what and
when i i i wish this was a joke but it's
now on google maps right you know you
can find the farm now yeah exactly
exactly
i'm sorry i interrupted yeah no no so
what was the customary background of
people that signed up for the cia if
they didn't join out of college what do
they spend those two years doing or
three years or five years or whatever so
so usually it's people that have had you
know three to five years experience in
some other job a lot of people are are
have law degrees
that go into that go into the agency
um you know business people or also we
get a lot of folks that come out of the
military that have had a long um you
know at least a decade in the military
that was that was kind of uh some of the
profile um during my time when i went in
in the early 2000s
okay so you go to the farm they whip you
into shape they teach you how to extract
intelligence and develop assets
and all of this uh fun stuff that we all
read about and watch movies about uh and
then what was your first assignment
my first assignment was in india and i
spent two years there
i was based in in new delhi
and um it was it was a great gig uh
india is is is a wild place i was all
over the country um and then and then
after that two years in in pakistan
primarily in islamabad
and it was it was fascinating uh the
issues in india and pakistan the same
issues you do you work on the same
issues but it's literally the exact
opposite right um and then i did two
years in new york city where i did a lot
of interagency work uh worked a lot with
um folks on on counter proliferation
related items with me uh nypd and such
and then a year and a half in
afghanistan where i manage our
undercover operations there
um so you're like a six foot two black
dude um
uh
for whatever reason i'm imagining you
being in india you'd be very conspicuous
so so here's what's funny right when i
grow a beer when i grow a beard you know
i could shape it in a way where it's a
little bit more pointed some people may
think i'm egyptian
right when i was in pakistan i i had
learned urdu and and it was survival
urdu right so i i was i was functionally
illiterate urdu speaker right i could
speak it i couldn't read it um but i
grew along beer and i wore like a shawar
chemise and you know people thought i
was just like the biggest pakistani
they'd ever seen right um and and my my
already was good enough i got the locals
discount in the bazaar right wow that's
impressive stuff man so you're like the
vin diesel of operatives
like ambiguous ethnic background
sure but but but here's the other thing
i tell you like when i speak in schools
i always talk about you know i'd always
talk to young to young women to say you
always hear about james bond but julia
bond was way cooler like the the
officers that worked for me my best
officers were always women and and you
know look i i had a i had an officer her
her call sign um stood for it it
translated into boogeyman in in a
certain dialect and she was five foot
tall blonde hair and she got the bomb
the size of the oklahoma city bombing
off the streets and so so you know you
the way you look and your ability to fit
in is only one part of only one tool in
your tool kit uh when you're using
tradecraft to collect intelligence on
threats to our homeland and so uh so
yeah so i blended in in some places some
places i didn't um but but that's just
only you know that's only one piece of
the part of the puzzle
do you know you get a different netflix
depending on which country you're
streaming from so netflix literally
hides thousands of shows and movies from
you based on your location now you could
get mad about this because they're
increasing their prices and so you could
cancel your subscription in protest or
you could be smart about it and get
expressvpn like we do so
you may not know that what's on netflix
in your country is completely different
from someone in the uk or japan and what
they have on theirs if you use
expressvpn you can control which country
you want netflix to think you're in so
expressvpn has over 90 countries to
choose from so every time i run out of
stuff to watch i just change my country
up and i can switch to another country
and unlock new shows and here's the best
part it's not just for netflix you can
use expressvpn to unlock a show on other
streaming services too hulu or apple tv
or you name it expressvpn is also super
fast and works on your phone laptop even
smart tvs so you can watch your shows on
big screens with zero buffering so
here's the deal we want you to stop
paying full price for streaming services
that don't give you all the shows they
have get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com
yang don't forget to use our link so you
can get three extra months of expressvpn
free that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash yang expressvpn.com
yang
[Music]
your book opens up with a very jarring
and honest story about you
in a something of an automotive mishap
where i think you ran over the heel of a
poor woman in india
and then everyone got really mad at you
and then you managed to calm the
situation down because they were kind of
surprised you were engaging which is
something of a metaphor for the book
uh
book overall um and you say
that one of the first lessons they teach
you
at the farm is to get off the x
what first what does that mean in second
what is the metaphor you're trying to
save for the entire country like what is
the x that we're on right now sure so so
so the second lesson you learn at the
farm is get off the x the first lesson
is actually lock your car doors right
it's it's that it's that it's that
simple um and get off the x the x is the
place where something's going down and
that's the last place you want to be
where something's going down right and
and for me i i feel like and i open the
book with this with this story um as a
metaphor for where we are in the country
because it may not seem illogical that
you know the the infighting that we're
seeing in in america has any connection
but it does because we're at a point in
time where we have to do something
different the the hyper partisanship
that is that is eroding our ability to
have any kind of serious a public disk
score to have to get any big thing done
we got to get away from it we got to get
off the edge so i go back to those
things i learned when i was 22 years old
23 years old
and that's why i started the book off
with with get off the x um because we
are at a point where this political
polarization
is is eroding trust in every one of our
institutions and and and that's a
problem and if we get away from that and
we show some compassion uh we we
we we might be able to see uh the the
body politic react the way um they
reacted when i was in this alley almost
getting dragged out of my car
yeah it was a very honest story because
who the heck wants to admit that they
ran over some poor woman's heel i mean
you know it's like
it looks like wait a way to establish
trust with the reader because i was like
oh man i don't know if i'd be
be admitting that you know i mean it's
fine obviously i mean you know you're on
a mission it was a crowded uh uh
alleyway um so a number of years later
you're in afghanistan and you're giving
an intelligence briefing to members of
congress and then one of them asks you
hey what's the difference between sunni
and shia and then you think he's kidding
and then he's serious and you're like oh
no
this is
uh this is not where we need our
leadership to be and you describe this
is one of the things that eventually led
you to run for congress a number of
years later
uh
can you describe that experience sure of
course and look what i my time in the
agency my job was to recruit spies and
steal secrets right and i was able to do
it in cool places um did it with some
amazing colleagues it was awesome
working on the most important national
security issues of the day but in
addition to doing that i often had to
brief members of congress that had come
out to our to to the embassies and and
wanted to get a briefing on what was
going on in that country and so i
probably
briefed 200 members rsds men women for
all 50 states right and and to be frank
i was pretty shocked at the caliber of
our elected officials right these were
men and women look
i don't expect
everybody to be an expert on everything
but if you're on the financial services
committee you should know the difference
between an investment bank a credit
union and a commercial bank right if
you're on the intelligence committee and
you've been on it for many years
you should know the difference between
sunni and shia and and what what made it
even worse when this experience happened
a bomb had just gone off in front of our
embassy that night about four three four
o'clock in the morning and my unit was
responsible trying to figure out what
happened
and so we conducted a couple dozen
operations in a very short period of
time
and we had a briefing we had a
congressional briefing that night and so
i go in
and you know we're supposed to be in
business casual right i'm kind of in
tactical gear when i was when i was in
afghanistan my hair was long and i said
earlier i had a beard and and um i walk
in the first thing i hear is a member of
congress asking is the cia gonna cut
this briefing short so we can get to the
bazaar to buy rugs all right so i'm
pissed i'm pissed before the before the
briefing even started
we go in
and and he asked like he the the
question was
was on why was iran
not this is
2008 by the way why was iran supporting
not supporting groups in afghanistan the
way they were supporting some groups in
iraq now it's a pretty mediocre question
and i started explaining the sunni shia
divide and that's when this guy raises
his hand he goes well what's the
difference between sunni and ashiya
and i'm getting ready to make a i
thought he was going to make an
inappropriate joke and my response was i
don't know congressman what's the
difference because i'm thinking i'm
getting ready to go but i'm pumped up
right you know and his face his face
turns bright red didn't know that
difference right and and to me
this is someone that's making decisions
on sending our boys and girls to places
like at the time iraq afghanistan
pakistan these are people that are
making decisions on how to spend
billions of our hard-earned dollars
taxpayer dollars and to not know
something that basic that undergirded
the global war on terrorism to me is
unacceptable it's okay for my brother
not to know this because he sells cable
here in san antonio but it's not okay
for someone like that and for me that
was just another example of things i saw
from our elected leaders that were doing
the exact opposite of what my friends
and i were trying to do and putting
ourselves in harm's way in order to
protect our country and so
it's one of the one of the things that
made me made me want to run
so doing the math it seems like you'd be
deciding to run in your early 30s uh
that seems very difficult to gear up for
a congressional run uh and i'm not sure
if there were resources available
as a former cia
officer
uh was was this like something that um
you had some help doing or how the heck
did you get started
look uh there was not a pipeline for
former caa officers and and it was hard
to basically what's called roll my cover
back to say that i was in the c.i.a uh
it would have been it would have been
awkward to uh go around kissing wait
wait before you go into this direction
how does one leave the cia is it like a
gang where you're like not allowed to
leave you gotta fight got to fight your
way out no no i'm um no look look the
the agency was super supportive of my
departure because they knew
and i was leaving not because i had an
axe to grind but because i thought i
could help the intelligence community in
a different way and so all the things
necessary um to leave and to be able to
talk about look in my entire
nine and a half years
the only time i ever said those three
letters the cia was when i recruited
somebody because you want to make it
very clear who they're working for other
than that i've never seen said those
three letters and then when you're
running for congress i said cia like a
hundred times a day it was sure man
but but here is here was my logic
that went into running
because i had run for student body
president a m
and i think i got like i got close to i
got over 12 000
thousand votes uh for to be student to
be sitting probably president a m
what i knew i needed to win a primary
at the time it was close to like
17 18 19 000 votes so i'm thinking and
and then when i ran for student body
president i could only spend like 300
right
um and so so i was like okay we're
almost there and then when i went and
looked um and so so i did have the idea
for me running for congress literally
started at a tex-mex restaurant in in
washington dc
with a good friend of mine and his best
friend who had run campaigns before so i
had a guy who was part of what's called
the nrcc on the national republican
congressional committee they're the ones
that trying to get more republicans and
the democrats have one to the d triple c
and so he had worked at the nrcc it was
like hey will um we think you'd be i i
think it'd be great he knew me in
college and so it started with
understanding
how many votes do i need to win
where do i find those votes
um how do i build a a a an organization
um is going to that i need in order to
get those votes and so it really did get
down to understanding the data and how
many votes i needed in each county and
what i needed to do
i didn't need to do something that had
never been done and at the time the 23rd
now
or when i ran was was when i won was 29
counties at the time i think was only 23
and i knew the most important was san
antonio bear county where i lived that i
was going to lose because i didn't have
i hadn't been there for a long time
but what i had to do in all those other
counties was come close to doing the
best performance that had ever happened
i didn't have to do the best performance
i didn't have to out you know out kick
you know coverage i just had to get near
what had already been done in many of
those but i had to do it all at the same
time and and that was that was our
strategy and so
um look
i was a government employee i wasn't
independently wealthy my parents don't
have money and so i sat and called
friends and family and asked them for
money uh to build an organization that i
could go out and talk to folks and then
i spent a lot of miles on my car a lot
of miles and showed up to places and
that's what people appreciated and i
kept showing up and and folks liked
my background they thought it was
interesting and um and i won that i won
i won that first round i lost a runoff
because i made a i made a strategic and
a tactical mistake um but but i came out
on top when nobody thought i was going
to be able to make it in a primary i'm
at a time when and this was when the tea
party was big and tea party had endorsed
somebody else the establishment
republicans endorsed somebody else but i
was able i was able to get um the pole
position out of five and i lost the
runoff but then came back a couple years
and one
how was your stress level
mine is never particularly great
and people don't always realize that
physical symptoms like headaches and
teeth grinding and even digestive issues
can be indicators of stress let's not
forget about doom scrolling sleeping too
little sleeping too much
under eating or overeating these are all
stress stuff now i'm proud to say this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy and i've used better help
personally a bunch of different ways um
in terms of what i'm coping with but
stress is a big one because it shows up
in so many different ways and in a world
that's telling you to do more or sleep
less and grind more
this is a friendly reminder to take care
of yourself and better help has online
therapists and personal counseling
sessions that you can talk about
anything online 24 7
it's amazing so how it works you go
online get match with a therapist that's
right for you and you get access to them
via text or video chat whenever you want
at your convenience and you can do it as
many times a month as you like it is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy so you can give it a
try and see how online therapy can help
lower your stress this podcast is
sponsored by better help forward podcast
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
yang so that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash yang
[Music]
that first run and then losing um must
have been
difficult yeah yeah because it was clear
that you put a lot of miles on that car
and you you worked your heart out um
i've lost a campaign or two
so
afterwards you know like people don't
realize just how
uh exhausting and depleting it is not
just like in a physical level but on
this emotional level
look and you you know this the thing
that's the hardest and i think this is
where you and i probably probably are
the
same we got people that had never been
involved in the political process
engaged and excited
right like that was my secret there were
these were people that were not
well i shouldn't tell this story my
brother gets mad when i tell this story
but my brother my brother's four years
older than me
and he was like my number one super
volunteer right he was doing everything
like he was you know you know all the
crazy things you have during the
campaign in like
six months in
my brother turns in one day he goes so
what's a primary again
and i'm like don't worry big guy just
keep doing what you're doing okay you
don't you don't need that bit right um
and and so it was people like my brother
people
like there you know so many families
that had never been involved in politics
that were excited right
and so when we won so look the first
round everybody was like okay you're
probably you're probably not going to
win this you know nobody ever wins their
first time and when we won and the
papers and everybody's right like man
he's the next best thing and then to
loot and look the other side my opponent
in the primary we knew his staffers
literally had put their um resumes out
because they thought they were going to
lose and they were looking for other
jobs right and to lose that and the gut
punch it was for all those people that
had done something they had never done
before
man i felt like i let them down and and
that that to me was the part that was
the hardest right
and but hillary was fascinating they all
stayed kind of they all started paying
attention to politics and and started
voting more and and and and asking
better questions and so so at least you
know inspiring that spark in people and
then when we got smarter and we came
back um we were able to pull it off
so 2014 you are now a member of congress
uh so you're working with a lot of
people
um
i know you drove to
dc at least once with our mutual friend
beto o'rourke uh so
you'd been in dc before as a cia
operative uh what was it like arriving
as a member of congress were you like
okay it's time to get [ __ ] done like you
know like wait
is it like the giant um high school for
adults that i think a lot of people
imagine
well well look so a couple of things a
little bit yes it is um i remember so
two weeks after you win
you get to you're in dc
and this is part of it's an orientation
and you're getting your office and stuff
like this and i remember
and like there's a weird lottery right
i'm like i'm like just give me an office
right like i don't care like give me the
offer
and then the guy who's gonna be my chief
of staff is he's like he's like well um
i need to check i wanna see it was like
for like
two hundred dollars i was like what do
you need to check for two hundred
dollars for he goes
for paint for the walls i was like
i gotta i gotta pay for the paint in the
in the and the walks on my office i'm
like this is weird right and so so
you get up there i had never been
involved in congress i never interned up
there my chief of staff was on my
closest friend who had spent time up
there and you're having to hire
you know up to 28 people in a short
period of time because of my district
was so big
i had four offices across the district i
would fly in and out of three different
airports and so so getting that up
getting getting up and running flat
footed and because it went from from a
democrat to a republican
there wasn't much sharing of information
and and proper handoff right and so so i
was learning a lot of this stuff um on
my own and and for me look i i knew
because of how how you know i i won i
forget i think that first election i won
by a couple thousand votes
that
my re-election already started and
people are gonna be coming at me and so
the value proposition that i made to the
voters
was
listen i heard from everybody they they
got sick and tired say never saw their
member they felt like they didn't have a
connection
and my value proposition was you're
gonna see me
and before i went to take the oath of
office first i hit all 29 counties and
and you know and did town halls to kind
of you know get my marching orders for
my bosses you know people always people
always say oh your boss i'm like my boss
is not the speaker of the house it's not
the president it's not the majority of
the leader of the minority leader my
bosses are those 800 000 people i
represent right and and so so i knew
that that my re-election was gonna be
based off of did i do all the things
that i said i was gonna do
and and so so i wanted to hit the ground
running fast the guy i beat had never
gotten a piece like that one piece of
legislation signed the law so i was
trying to think about you know how do i
do legislation how do i make sure
constituents are getting answered so
it's a whirlwind it's a whirlwind um for
a lot of members especially ones that
come from competitive districts when you
first get up there
so your i think anyone watching and
listening to this is now registered that
you're uh what's called a reasonable or
sane republican
take it i'll take it yeah
um
you're also very bipartisan you
co-sponsored legislation with beto uh
after it sounds like this 18-hour road
trip that you guys streamed
um so everyone got to watch the the two
of you choose tunes and the rest of it
you co-sponsored reasonable immigration
legislation with pete aguilar
and that this was one of the most
harrowing stories in your book
where
apparently you were only three votes
away from getting reasonable immigration
reform across the table
uh and then uh you had like this clutch
of principled republicans like yourself
and then republican leadership came in
and said hey how about you walk away
from that and we'll
do this other thing for you that doesn't
really matter and then enough members
were like okay i'll i'll do that um so
you want to share that story because i
couldn't believe when i was reading it
in your book i was like oh my gosh we
actually had a chance to pass that yeah
look it it's it's probably
still one of the things i'm still like
most pissed off about and
because look it to me
immigrant
immigration is important to the success
of our country right let's start there
right there's a reason the longest
chapter in my book is on immigration and
border security and and because because
we have benefited from the brain gain of
every other country um for the last
75 years
and and if we were streamlining legal
immigration
we would relieve some of the pressure
that we're seeing right now um on the
border uh we would be addressing some of
the the employee shortage
that we're seeing in so many industries
i actually it widens the tax base so you
have more people paying in i look i talk
about a new cold war with china
that the chinese government um that uh
they've been stealing our technology and
our intellectual property uh let's steal
their engineers right like so so to me
it's so important and so we got close
in to do
what was called a discharge position
long-winded way it's a super arcane rule
that jams
the leadership of the house to bring a
bill to the floor
we had a bill called the usa act and
this is what pete and i had been working
on for months
it addressed daca or the dreamers it
addressed border security it addressed
some of the root causes um like the the
economic problems in the northern
triangle el salvador guatemala and
honduras and it addressed the um uh the
the immigration judicial system
and so
every democrat signed on to this bill
or this the discharge
and we needed i forget the total number
of republicans but we got up to
we had two votes we had two more
signatories of this letter and this had
to be done by a specific date because of
the way the rules of the house operated
and we knew if this bill came to the
floor
it would get over 240
votes right you only need 218 to pass
and the same bill this usa act had had
been worked on in the senate this was
when um senator mccain was still alive
it went up for a vote and it came four
votes shy
of of hitting of getting cloture right
three votes try to gain cloture
and that was that we knew the political
environment was different that if it
passed the house in a bipartisan way it
would probably put pressure we knew on
which republicans would potentially vote
and get and get this bill and and guess
what um president trump would have
signed this bill into law
and so
at the end we almost we had our two
names
they were like well we're telling the
team that we're working on this we're
gonna get that we're gonna sign there
and then and then and then republican
leadership came in and offered something
that pulled them away
and those of us that you know the the
the renegades
um you know me and the renegade said oh
we're going to try this other option and
we were so close to making it happen and
upset but but here's what makes me even
more upset that was republican
leadership killed that bill 100
i can say that
that same bill
would still get 240 votes if it got
brought to the floor today right and so
democrats loved it at the time i'm gonna
i'm not trying to be partisan here and
drew no no go ahead right like they they
they were all on board and jamming and
forcing republican leadership to do
something right but when it comes their
chance to do it
they're unwilling to do it because
they're afraid instead of working with
the 20 to 30 republicans that would make
this bipartisan give them the votes
they're afraid of their far left flank
from criticizing this and because it may
not go too far right and that's why and
it's so frustrating that immigration
even though if you look at republican
primary voters and democratic primary
voters they actually pretty much see eye
to eye most people agree on like an
invisible middle ground approach yeah
for sure but both sides but political
leaderships on both sides would rather
use this issue as a political bludgeon
to hit each other over the head with
rather than to solve the problem it's
super frustrating it's something that we
gotta address and it's something that be
even even more important impactful right
now considering the number of crises
that we're doing
yeah i mean the story was fascinating
because it sounded like every democrat
was for this bill and then you were part
of like this group of maybe you know a
dozen or two dozen uh republicans who
were kind of sticking your neck out uh
and then uh trying to get it done
um
and the fact that it came that close was
like oh i hadn't heard about any of this
um one of the things i felt reading your
book was like whoa you know it's like i
got a very different version of that
story
[Music]
so i remember i was running for
president and
uh then president trump uh ordered the
uh killing of suleimani the
uh iranian leader
uh and i remember pr the press just
pillarying him for that as if it was
like a very very rash action
and in your estimation it was actually
appropriate and
uh followed through on an earlier u.s
commitment
look what 100 it was and this notion
that so
if there are not consequences
to negative behavior negative behavior
is going to continue
and and qasim suleimani when he was the
head of the iranian could iranian irgc
iranian revolutionary guard could force
this would be like um
the equivalent of navy seals and the cia
being merged together this this is
ultimately what he ran and this was an
organization that has been labeled as a
terrorist organization like this is not
this is not me
using a using hyperbole this was state
on state department list u.n all this
stuff and this is an individual who has
been responsible for killing thousands
of american soldiers right and that's
just american soldiers not many many of
our allies and this notion was that we
always talk about escalation an
escalation is getting a lot of the
conversation right now when we're
dealing with russia and what is going to
escalate and and if you do this this is
going to cause open conflict what
happened that's what the criticism was
yeah right and and and guess what what
happened
the the iranians we knew they were going
to respond they gave a tacit
they gave a a a a a very weak response
that we were able to defend against so
that they can say haha we responded uh
you you terrible people and and then
guess what everybody went on their way
and so it was the right move you know
one of the things i i talk about and
this is this is actually when the
chapter is one of the sections in the
book where i talk about when it comes to
foreign policy
our foreign policy should be simple your
friend should love you
and your enemies should fear you
and and and and when the international
order the international order has been
has worked and has benefited americans
when america uses our economic and
military power to uh to to to support it
and and that has led to 70 years of
peace and prosperity in europe that
allowed have us a major trading partner
the global gdp between the
u.s and europe have 50 of global gdp
that has been beneficial to to to to all
americans in our economy and so we can't
be afraid to use this application of
force and again i disagree with donald
trump on a lot of things right but this
was one that that i agree with him on
yeah there's another very affecting
story where you were in a helicopter
helping pakistanis who were
trapped in the rubble of an earthquake
aftermath
and there was a little girl
that
had lost her parents uh and was afraid
to come in the helicopter and then you
uh personally comforted her and then
brought her in the helicopter uh and so
when people imagine
uh the
perception of americans in other parts
of the world uh you know you've actually
been part of saving lives uh as
a positive application of american
assets and resources
look america has become an exceptional
nation not because of what we have taken
but because of what we have given and
and i was lucky to see that up close and
personal i was lucky to to to be take
take part in in the many of those kinds
of activities and we we'd forgotten you
know prior to 9 11
if you were in pakistan if you would
talk to any any person under the age of
40
their first experience with western
culture would have been at a a
um
the american center in one of the major
cities in in pakistan and american
centers are separate from the embassies
of the consulate but it's like a big
community building right so you have a
library there you can listen to rock
music you can look at the latest
pictures of of life magazine a lot of of
of pakistanis when they applied to
universities they use tools at these
american centers right like this this
soft power right this this public
diplomacy is one of the things that has
helped make america what it is today
after 9 11 all of our facilities
overseas became bunkers and they became
the most fortified location in those
places now they're i'm not i'm not
criticizing that completely
but when you free when you fail to
engage
with communities when you show that
you're more afraid
of a community because you're because
you're afraid of what's going to happen
to you
that's where our standing and the rest
of the world i'm started started eroding
and and again we benefit foreign policy
is not foreign
and and i can make an argument that
america has been isolationists more than
it's not been right george washington
warned us about entangling alliances
right well the world has changed a lot
since my man you know george washington
was was president right and it's
interesting very uh very fearful of
political parties but continue
[Laughter]
but he he saw he foresaw what was going
to happen right yeah he did um and so so
anyway so so i i think that is something
that that that my perspective and
opinions on foreign policy have been
have been shaped by my time in the cia
but also working alongside of my cop my
the diplomatic corps um working
alongside of men and women in usaid
meeting all of these great ngos that are
in in tough environments trying to do
better and so so look we we have we we
we've been lucky as a country to to be
able to improve the quality of life of
our own citizens but but also to uplift
humanity and and that when america is
doing that
we're at our best
so you're a republican who
believes in the threat of climate change
has been trying to do things about it
your family has personally experienced
racism
uh your
family was denied housing sometimes on
the basis of race
uh i think when you were in congress you
were one of either two or three black
members of the house that were
republican
um and i i think a lot of people
watching and listening this was like wow
you know like uh i i could see myself
supporting someone like
will
one thing you don't know actually is
that the reason why my team reached out
to you is that i was
with some friends
uh in silicon valley in the tech world
and then they said if there's one person
who understands this stuff uh out of
congress it's will heard and then i said
oh really like how do i not know this
fellow like oh let
let us reach out
um you were in a competitive district uh
kind of managing something very very
difficult which was you were uh winning
races uh as the
country was kind of
whipsawing back and forth uh served
three terms
why did you decide to abbreviate uh your
your time uh in the house
so so andrew
these positions
weren't designed
for people to be in them forever
right and are you like beto uh pro term
limit sounds like you are
it's funny it's funny right so i i got
criticized i got criticized early on
because i said i was against term limits
because my argument was if you don't
like who's in there go vote when when
the average num in a primary
in in 2018 the last non-presidential
election um the average number of voters
in a contested primary was 54 000 people
that's not a lot of people right
and and so so it's like you know the the
ability to to to go go go beat somebody
right that was my point and so when i
walked away those same people that were
critical of me
for not for not supporting tournaments
like why are you walking away i'm like
i'm walking away because you don't have
to die or be defeated to leave these
positions um two i think i think this
this back and forth you know getting
experience doing something in for
service in your in your country and then
getting out coming back in you know it
makes you smarter it makes you more
well-rounded um had i lost when i lost
in in that 2010 election
my ability to go in in the private
sector and start help start a cyber
security company that informed me of a
lot of things that made me a more
effective member of congress and so so
so i i had said when i ran the first
time that these jobs have a have a shelf
life six seven or eight years
and i said okay it was gonna be six and
and then the opportunity for me
like
and and this is another thing i think we
agree on
um
the technological questions that we're
gonna have to ask ourselves and deal
with over the next couple years are
pretty significant
and and so to be and the only way that
we're going to be able to deal with
these ques these issues and then do it
within a competition between us and the
chinese government is if the public in
the private sector are working together
and so now being out in private sector
and helping you know uh
supporting entrepreneurs and in
artificial intelligence and quantum
computing and biotech i i've i've
learned a lot already and and i tell i
think i have you can see you can see
that that's an actual typewriter you
know
and i show that to kids when i speak to
high schools nobody knows what it is and
when i open it out of the box everybody
ooh and oz right and i said look i used
that when i was in eighth grade
and it's it's old and outdated and then
i whip out my cell phone and say and
imagine when this cell phone is gonna
get old and outdated which which it's
going to happen sooner rather than later
so so that's one of the reasons why i
decided to pursue other opportunities
well you had a much clearer perspective
on the competition with china than i
think i've seen from just about any
other political figure you have multiple
chapters you worked in technology
you're working in the field now
in various capacities
[Music]
so
uh it sounds like you've made
uh an appeal that was uh i want to say
it kind of transcended party um uh i'm
guessing that you're probably somewhat
concerned about the direction of the
republican party over the this
past period i mean you did disagree with
trump on a whole lot of things when he
was in office and there are some stories
in the book about him calling you and
being like hey you want to vote like
this and you're like sorry mr president
can't do that and then he would uh you
know rant at you for a little while
yeah harangue i think harang would be
the right would be the right word yeah
yeah
uh yeah so um how do you think i i see
uh reasonable republicans of which i
believe there are millions as the most
important pivot group in the country and
i i know many um and they're very
concerned that the republican party has
become the party of trump
uh
and that they'd like to do something
about it but the mechanics make it
difficult
um do you have any thoughts i'm sure you
have friends who resemble the same thing
sure no look i i agree with all your
your your your your your points um
the problem in our politics is that is
that the political electorate is no
longer is no longer a line it's a
horseshoe right
and the the
that means the edges are closer to each
other than they are the middle and
eighty percent of americans care about
putting food on the table a roof over
their head and making sure that people
they love are healthy happy and safe and
they don't wear a particular jersey or
they they may they may like one color
more than the other but they're willing
they're willing to to to to ebb and flow
um and so so
both sides of the political aisle that
should care
independence should care
for party members should care right the
people that don't vote for should care
because we need to have a real strong
competition of ideas and whether that's
between two parties whether that's
between three parties that's the only
way we're gonna solve these challenges
and what i call
the authoritarian wing of the republican
party um i you know look one of the
reasons i'm republicans i believe that
the concentration of power in the hands
of the few is a bad thing now um my
friends on on the democratic side of the
aisle trying to concentrate power in the
government my friends in the
authoritarian wing and the republican
party are trying to concentrate that
power in one person right and and i i
think those are all bad things now
i would say president trump's um
influence over the electorate has been
waning and it's going to continue to
wane um up until up until 2024 and and
that
you're seeing
down ballot candidates um win even
though they don't have the support of of
donald trump and so i look it's it's
he still probably has a solid third of
republican primary electorate but if you
look at the number of people that
consider themselves conservative who
vote in general elections but not the
primaries that's a significant bunch
right and and i think that's where
there's there's an opportunity but but
look the other side and andrew you know
this better than some
republicans are going to win in 20 they
take the house back in 2022 that's
almost a fatal complete and likely to
pick up the senate and part of that
is because of what i would say is is
incompetence on on the democratic party
side to get some things that people care
about done and they focus on things that
the majority of americans don't care
about
and so if you don't have two parties you
know uh uh what what's that what's the
phrase iron sharpening iron when you
don't have two parties that are that are
really involved in them yeah why was
that not the case in american life yeah
like iron chirping is not the way anyone
would think of these two parties
now look for sure i i i agree with you
on that and and and so so but it's to me
you know i was um
i was i was at south by southwest a
number of years ago this is the the big
tech um movie
um music show yeah i'm a veteran
i'm trying to explain it for you for
your audience right just in case um
and and i'm on the panel
i'm on a panel with a bunch of youtube
stars
there was four other people and combined
those other four had a billion
subscribers on their youtube channels
and i think at the time
i had 50 right and so i'm like why am i
on this panel
with with all these people and one of
them was the digital director for the
rock dwayne johnson
and and this is when the movie moana was
coming out
and and she's like look if moana fails
at the box office
are we gonna blame moviegoers for not
coming in the movies or are we gonna say
it was a crummy movie right she's like
she's like obviously you could say it's
a common movie now moana i thought was a
delightful movie i'm not criticizing
moana anyway
and but she goes but politics
is the only industry
where you blame the person
that is that you're trying to sell the
good or service to
rather than blaming the product right
and that always stuck in my head and
that we we run um a lot of times we run
campaigns the way they've always been
run we always think about the past oh
yeah man it's the freaking consultant
class it's one reason why you won is you
just had some homegrown people who
believed in you and loved you absolutely
and did it my way did it my way right
and and so
so so look it it's it's it's um um
the these political conversation debates
are valuable and we got to get to a
point where we can where we can we can
debate we can disagree without being
disagreeable um and and i think we need
to like look i i'm of the opinion that
the
uh that the republican party can be
remade it's gonna be a long time it's
gonna be hard it's a difficult task um
but but somebody that has been involved
in electoral politics i see i feel like
that's something that that is that is uh
well hey having having patriots like you
trying to remake the republican party is
an awesome and uh admirable project
uh and a lot of us would love to see
people like you succeed i've got a
personal question for you that was
burning me up while i was reading this
book um so you're in your mid-40s and as
of the writing of the book you were
somehow single and so i thought to
myself is will like the most eligible
bachelor
uh ever and this is part of the
fictional character thing it's like i
was a spy
i was a member of congress i'm tall dark
and handsome and i am single
well andre i'm gonna be in new york in a
couple of weeks if you know anybody um
look i i was i was engaged once i was
engaged once and um when you come home
and say hey honey
um guess what
i actually work in the cia and we're
moving to pakistan
that has a chilling that has a chilling
effect on on on a relationship and so um
and then and then i i know i've had
serious relationships since but but
going back and forth
you know every being in dc three nights
a week and then being you know probably
traveling a couple thousand miles a
weekend and that put that puts a toll um
on on on a relationship but yes i am i
am still a bachelor so well you heard it
here people so yeah you know
[Laughter]
will is on twitter
i don't know how actually he email email
and he could connect us yeah
yes no well we we should resolve this
matter this is of national security
my mom would appreciate you my mom can
consider this a national security issue
as well yeah
yeah i think we all should truly uh as a
problem solver it's gonna bother me
until it's done
um so i'm i'm going to ask you a
question that others are going to be
thinking um so you're clearly a very
uh principled
uh you call yourself an idealist um on
the
book cover um you wrote a book which i
enjoyed a great deal uh and found a lot
to
um to think about in it so the obvious
question is uh do you imagine another
run for office in your future
look if if i'm able to serve my country
in in a different way then i'm gonna
evaluate it right um and so so i'm not
ruling anything out in the the if the
opportunity comes great and but but to
me you can't think of anything but the
next election right and the next
election is 22 i'm not going to be on
the ballot and so so if the opportunity
comes like i said i'll think about it
and and and can i win a future election
the way
i've always won mine right i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna be
i'm gonna do it my way right that's why
i've always done it and if i can do it
my way and there's an opportunity and i
feel like um i i have something to give
to the to the country then i'll think
about it
well let let me say there are a lot of
people listening to this that are going
to hope that you run again because uh
your party in your country could really
really use you will thank you so much
american reboot fantastic book and uh we
look forward to remaining in touch and
making sure that your mom's happy and we
get you
uh our next the next podcast will be us
on a double date how about that
yeah my wife would enjoy that uh thank
you so much will it's been a blast and a
pleasure pleasure was mine brother thank
you
[Music]
you